when an interactive artwork
forms an engagement
with people in the audience
you can watch a sort of conversation
develop the artwork's not really fully
realized until those interactions have
been allowed to occur
my name's geoffrey drake brockman and
i'm a cybernetics artist
i work in the most isolated city in the
world perth western australia
for a long time i had two parallel lives
i was an i.t guy a computer programmer
and i was also a painter
i kept the whole idea of art completely
separate from computation and that just
sort of led to a crisis i thought what
am i doing who am i kidding
so i let it in and suddenly i was making
artworks which were robotic
cybernetics is about interaction it can
be made out of any kind of technology
you can use electronics computers even
clockwork to enable
conversations to take place between
people and
artworks for me the whole point of using
technology in art is to make an artwork
interactive with interactivity you can
get deep audience engagement people look
at a piece for hours on end instead of
just a minute
when i complete an artwork i like to
watch it respond to its audience i watch
to see how the play between the artwork
and the audience develops sometimes i
saw people who were treating the artwork
as though it was a person they were
smiling at it waving to it
talking to it i thought how far can we
take this
the part that i love most of all is when
it's done when the vision is realized
when i can set the artwork free and
watch you interact with people it's
actually doing what it's meant to do and
creating what it's meant to create
[Music]
you